-♪ From the City of
Brotherly Love ♪
-♪ That's Philly ♪
-♪ Comes a brother
that you love by the name ♪
-♪ Big Willie ♪
♪ You seen him in Billboard
starring in shows ♪
♪ But there's a lot about him
that you might not know ♪
-♪ Like what? ♪
-♪ Actor, rapper ♪
-♪ Nah, pleading the fifth ♪
♪ Jimmy, let's teach 'em all
something 'bout Will Smith ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Back in '85 ♪
-♪ I rocked the house
till it turned to rubble ♪
♪ Every time I told y'all girls
ain't nothing but trouble ♪
♪ Jeff's the DJ,
I'm the rapper ♪
♪ You can call him Jazz,
you can call me dapper ♪
♪ Then I was rappin' just
to make bus fare ♪
♪ Then I moved in with my Auntie
and Uncle In Bel Air ♪
-♪ I don't gotta tell you
that that show was awesome ♪
♪ Every Monday night before
an all new "Blossom" ♪
-♪ Six whole years
I lived with the Banks ♪
♪ So if you can dance
The Carlton ♪
♪ I still give thanks ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ But a real big star
needs a real big screen
♪ So I had to spread my wings
if you know what I mean ♪
♪ Went ham, no beef,
no Kevin Bacon ♪
♪ Even though we still connect
with
"Six Degrees of Separation" ♪
♪ What you gonna do
when you hear the siren noise ♪
♪ Me and Martin,
a couple of "Bad Boys" ♪
♪ "Independence Day,"
aliens on my turf ♪
♪ You invadin' us, nah
Welcome to Earth ♪
-♪ '97 married Jada
and she still set it off ♪
♪ Any questions you and she
can have a "Red Table Talk" ♪
-♪ Agent J "Men in Black"
keeping a file
♪ So y'all could get jiggy
with it Big Willie Style ♪
-♪ Na na na na na na ♪
♪ Bienvenidos a Miami ♪
-♪ Started out a Prince then
became the Fresh Papi ♪
♪ 'Cause Trey is the ace
Jaden's a force ♪
♪ Willow came and told y'all ♪
-♪ Whip your hair
back and forth ♪
-♪ "Wild, Wild West"
"Enemy of the State"-est ♪
-♪ Like Muhammad Ali said ♪
-♪ I'm the greatest ♪
-♪ From way back when
to the new Willennium ♪
-♪ "Shark Tale" played a fish
and was finnin' them ♪
♪ "Men in Black"
then "Bad Boys II"
-♪ Give him 60 seconds
he can solve a Rubik's Cube ♪
♪ Dropped lost and found
turn it over and switch ♪
-♪ He even got Kevin James
a date in "Hitch" ♪
-♪ Just pursuing my happyness
no tension ♪
-♪ Forget the wack rappers,
man, he am legend ♪
-♪ Joined "Suicide Squad,"
played Deadshot ♪
♪ That was after my super
powers then I found them
in "Hancock" ♪
-♪ He fought Ron Burgundy
in "Anchorman 2"
-♪ Then I bungee jumped out of
a chopper on YouTube ♪
-Aaahh!
-♪ Checking off my bucket list
enjoying the ride ♪
-♪ And if you haven't done it
please like and subscribe ♪
-♪ "Aladdin" ain't never
had a friend like me ♪
♪ And I turned into a pigeon
in my last movie ♪
♪ So whether G, Genie,
matchmaker, fish or a bird ♪
-♪ You're a good man ♪
-♪ Bad Boy for life ♪
-♪ Ya heard ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]